hi my name is Abdul Dhaka I'm a kernel
developer at Wolfram research my talk is
called the Wolfram kampala advances and
in this talk I'm going to talk about the
advances that we've made in the compiler
in the past year I'm gonna talk about
the type system the runtime system as
well as how to express certain logics
and then you can power to develop more
functionality within the okay so a
disclaimer so most of what you see is
kind of internal detail so you know you
know this stuff won't be exposed to the
users unless you really want to you know
so this is how we write the complete
it's mostly how we write the compiler
not like you know what you'd probably do
the title of the stock was like compiler
advances or something so the objective
of the compiler if I want to summarize
in a few words is we want people to
write Wolfram code we don't want them to
write C++ or assembly programming we
won't want them to write the word for
Wolfram code in fact the entire Wolfram
compiler is written in Mathematica
itself and Wolfram language we want
people to get similar speed to as if
their handwriting C++ code so kind of
remove the need for stuff like library
link and all of that there should be
predictable performance guarantees so
nothing where if I you know have a list
of a thousand I get you know 2x
performance but if I get if I increase
the list to 2001 I get 1x performance
that's kind of weird behavior we don't
want that and we want it to be
explainable that you know the semantics
and the design decisions should be
explained in kind of easy kind of
guidelines so nothing like you know this
part of the code behaves in some way and
then a different part of the code
there's in a different way so I'm gonna
kind of talk about you know some of the
kind of background material so the
current hardware which is what we're
targeting is many you know multi-core so
there's now you know 10 10 core 16 cores
200 core systems there's a lot of memory
you know 32 gigabytes is kind of you
know more or less standard at this point
in this case you know there's terabytes
of disk space people complain about 512
gigabytes of data and not be
enough you know a lot of the codes that
we are interested in you know might be
distributed and decentralized so they
might stand multiple machines so you
probably see that in the neural network
training and they also use specialized a
lot of the codes nowadays are using
specialized hardware for a certain task
so GPUs for example are specialized
hardware to do vector arithmetic so also
the current hardware has not increased
substantially in terms of ceará
performance over the past ten years so
you know over the years since 2007 the
serial performance has went you know as
has been steady vectorized which when I
mean vector is like sim D or single
instruction multiple data or you know
sometimes they you know you hear a V X
or SSE instructions those has you know
like there's you know they've every few
years they increase the vector size so
from you know the avx2 is about 512 bits
multi-threaded would give you also like
some sort of performance and then what
we're after is kind of vectorized and
threaded performance so that's what we
want the compiler to be able to generate
is vectorize code and multi-threaded
code the other thing that i think is
useful for people to know is that if I
look at a system like you know the slot
for example you know the compute power
is mostly so so you know so this is the
Alexi post post code you know you know
if I write C post was good but you know
if I write serial C++ code I would
should get you know this like whatever
ten gigaflops or something performance
if I write it with multi-threaded I
would get eighty gigaflops if I write it
with the vector intrinsic s-- I would
get you know 100 gigaflops or so but the
most power is in you know the GPU and
that's kind of what we're you know
trying to do is you know initially what
we're trying to do is give you this
performance and then eventually the GPU
formance it ends up that you know GP
code is more specialized so you cannot
write a lot of programs in GPUs so the
strategy for us from the compiler team
is to provide tools for you to do
program analysis code generation and
type inferencing and these are tools
that is supposed to be you know you can
also use you know you know so they would
be like you told these that the compiler
provides and we're aiming to generate
performance code and reduce magic so
instead of having you know kind of magic
rules we would have you know sensible
rules that can be explained clearly the
generated code I think this is something
useful is the generated code can be used
outside of the Wolfram language and I
think Connor showed that at two days ago
where he was doing debugging and he was
you know he was doing debugging LDB and
it was outside Mathematica we're mostly
targeting good modern and future
hardware so we're not interested for you
know machines you know like you know
machines from ten years ago
you know people can opt-in an opt-out of
certain optimizations or enable
debugging and then your advanced users
can write their own languages
essentially you know their own embedded
domain-specific languages from within
the mathematical at from within
Wolfram and then also people can
intermix Mathematica with C and assembly
and maybe LLVM so the compiler is
structured there's a kind of a pipeline
so I'll go over each one so initially
what we do is we take mathematical code
so this is you know stuff that you you
you usually program in and we translate
it into kind of a lower-level
representation this is still valid
Mathematica code is just kind of doesn't
have certain features for example
increment does not exist you know it's
it's just implemented there's a module
you know as a kind of a t-shirt
form of increment we then go from that
code into an intermediate code that that
intermediate code is untyped so this is
what Tom said you know this is the
what's called SSA form or single static
assignment form we then do type
inferencing on that intermediate
representation to generate this I pool
from I R and then we generate you know I
you know we generate LVM or c++ or you
know you know codes and then the execute
the code is executed either on arm or
you know intel or AMD hardware so the
AST or the abstract syntax tree is
essentially an expert and the expert
allows you to zoom in so this is a you
know we call this create a master which
just holds you know holds that expert in
a data structure and then you can do
queries on it so this is you know
showing the expert information so this
is a list and it has certain properties
that you can query then you could do
some some transformations on that expert
and in here what we're doing is you know
in the original program there's a two
x's and you know these this X is bound
to this module and this X is button to
this module so what we do is do we just
rename all the X's so that they're
unique so in here you know it's clear
now that this X dollar one is bound to
here and this X is bound to here by the
way you can stop at any point and ask
questions we also have a way to do
program analysis on the expressions so
one example is we can find which
variables are not bound in that
expression so if I have X plus y and
only access bound that I should expect
the free variables to be Y these are
kind of tools
we use and then there's other
transformation like function application
sometimes called beta reduction so if I
have a function it's kind of like a
function and I apply Z to it I get a
different for a new function where Y is
now bound to Z we also have on the
expert on the expressions we have a
thing called macros so these are similar
to scheme or Lisp macros so and they
work with a pattern language so one
example is I want it to have three
things I want it to have an
implementation of up to so up to is a
kind of a relatively new symbol which
gives you I mean essentially it's the
same but you know if I say take list up
to eight then it's you know if the list
is smaller than eight is still valid a
valid expression so what is doing is
just computing the min of the value and
the list so I can define take a macro on
take this says you know take of list up
to n is rewritten as take of list with
the min of length and N and now I can
then say macro expand the expert and I
get a new expression where now this
expression is re-written as take lists
min of Worcester min of Wilson ate the
macro system can also be used to perform
program optimizations and
transformations so a common optimization
is called loop fusion where if I have a
map of a map I can fuse the two
functions and get a new composition of
these two functions so I can define what
composition means
lengths of map of lists is essentially
yeah I don't really need to do map if
you just take the length of lists so
here and the map of F of G of lists is a
composition of F of G mapped to the list
and I'm also doing something like map of
F of take of map of you know G of list
is this thing you know yeah I could just
take the elements and then apply the the
map and now if I define this function
called no map of my phone one map of my
phone to take of not my phone three
lists up to eight yeah right right yeah
assuming there's no side effects yeah
yeah there's there's a side effect
analysis that we we run but I mean it
won't fit on a slide but now you know I
have I have this sort of function and if
I excuse this function kind of naively I
would go over this list you know there's
three loops that are going over the list
and now in this transformed code I'm
only iterating through the list one time
and I hope I didn't have to write that
much code to do that so these are these
are tools that we have in the compiler
that we use now the intermediate
representation is kind of also called I
R is something that's kind of like
machine independent assembly where now
you've lost a lot of information about
Mathematica there's no mathematical
construct in what you have is are things
like you know memory loads memory stores
branches and conditionals so you know if
I have this function type integer 64 and
then this counter and then I can you
know it translates into something that's
a bit harder to you know you don't
recognize that as a Mathematica code and
it's still more or less gibberish if you
you've not looked at these things for a
while so but initially you know you you
have a
you load an argument then you jump to
this guy and then you have a set of
instructions and then you have a branch
a condition that says you know if this
is true then jump to here otherwise jump
to the exit and in the wild body it
jumps to the condition again so you know
it becomes this sort of graph you know
that's kind of a loop and then once it
you know it's this condition is false it
gets to this while exit so the other
thing so that that's the Wolfram I or
the other thing is the type system so
the type system is and and this is
something that's important is that we
wanted to make it independent and we had
you know previous iterations of this but
we wanted to make it the new iteration
independent of the compilers so no types
are hard-coded and there's a lot of
presentations here that you know we're
talking about types proof theory
representation of you know different
structures the type system uses you know
essentially unification to infer missing
type so you essentially have a pattern
and you're trying to figure out what
what values satisfy this pattern it
supports things like abstract types and
I think one of the questions and Tom's
talk was whether these are similar to
type classes and they are so similar to
type classes and they're called
different things in different languages
some some like we just have different
feet you know they call different things
because they're slightly different but
they're more or less equivalent they
allow for type overlap so this is you
know if you know Haskell Haskell types
cannot overlap and they cannot they must
have the same number of arguments so
that duska relaxation from the Haskell
type system we allow sequences and
recursion we have some limited supported
dependent types of type of valuations
and the reason why the type system is
complicated or you know needs to be rich
is because if you have a type system
that is not rich then you get this thing
of you know you have code that should
work but you cannot represent it in the
type system so the code that can be well
typed and is you know works is small and
we want to maximize that as much as
possible so this kind of region where
the program works but is not well type
it's called the region of abysmal pain
because you kind of want it to work but
you have to kind of hack it or you
cannot express it in a certain way so
and sometimes like that's what a lot of
this like Scala and Haskell they they
try and reduce error and maximize this
this overlap as much as much as possible
so the type system is also organized in
you know as a set of type classes or
properties on types so we have things
like so we have things like equal and
you know there's a set of functions you
know a set of types that inhabit equal
and a set of functions that are needed
for you know to have the equality
property you know things that are
integrals and you know they have
quotients of mod and ceiling and there's
different types so this allows us to
organize types in a kind of a structured
way so now I'm going to come up with
some examples which you know kind of
stress test some of the compiler
features so one the first example is
compile time code generation so I want
to compute Fibonacci and I want to do it
at compile time rather than runtime so
Mathematica you could do that by saying
you know with F equals four Vannucci and
then kind of embed that F in the
function so if I do that then you get
function
that returns 55 now in in the compiler
there's different ways of representing
that same thing one way of doing it is
using macros so if I have a macro that's
called fib I can define what fib of 0
means in fib of 1 and I could say fib of
any integer is an evaluation to compute
a Fibonacci so if I then say macro
expand of fib of 30 and then show the
expression I get this thing which is
computed at compile time you know you
don't pay the penalty if you inject that
in the code to do it now you can also do
the this computation in the type system
and this is like you know not pretty but
you could do it and this is using
dependent types so if I say what the
type of fib of you know 1 & 2 & 3 are
type literals and then I could say you
know the type of Fibonacci of any
anything is actually this is not
Fibonacci this is factorial oh I renamed
it I renamed it then I renamed it to the
wrong thing it used to be factorial as I
was for the notch in the night but then
you could say your fib of 3 evaluates to
you know into 6 and that's just using it
the the type system you can also do
stuff that you could not do in
Mathematica which is for example if I
have if I want to generate vectorize
code this machine independent I can
write that in the type system so in here
I'm writing a an RGB to greyscale and
I'm using this type called Cindy vector
so this is you know a kind of a machine
vector and then I can use total and you
know some serve compiled intrinsics
to generate you know SSE code you know
if yes so c3 code
and this will work you know if I'm on
you know an ARM processor we generate
neon code or you know whatever the
equivalent stuff in you know film on
CUDA I would generate the right stuff so
then you can write you know stuff like
you know what dot me is what men means
and you know you get these kind of IRS
so the other thing that you know the
other so you know the other thing that I
wanted to look at was you know some
people are interested in you know like
doing Auto differentiation or defining D
in the compiler so you could do that in
again you know you can do that in the
macro system by defining some you know
some certain rules like you know an
integer derivative is zero and then you
know some sort of trig rules and then
you hold a sort of expansion rules so
plus of a B and then if you evaluate
that you know say macro expand D of sine
of X plus cosine of X with respect to X
you get you know the subtractive cosine
of X sine of X so that's fine you can
also do it in the type system so you
know this is not something that you
really wanted type but something you
could do you know there's app there's
other applications where you might want
to do this sort of stuff but you could
do it than the type system as well so I
think that's it
that's one way of doing it I mean you
could do it in a bunch of ways I mean
the thing is like you could do it that
way right
in C++ I could define a Fibonacci at
compile time using templates right
I mean the other thing is like sometimes
you want to compute properties and these
properties are only defined on the types
they might not be defined on the
variables or there might not be present
in the program so for example for
structured you know structured arrays
multiplying your two symmetric matrices
produces a symmetric matrix that's might
be in the type language but is
programmed so this is exactly the same
you know you and yeah yeah that
everything is written as a pass in the
compiler right yeah yeah I mean we
define passes all the time doing closure
conversion right now you can assign
properties on the expert that don't you
know you can say oh I visited this
expression right yeah yeah we have house
order traversal pre-order topological
order a bunch of orders yeah
I tell
the other thing is we're breaking so we
started this with a type system we're
breaking some of the stuff that could be
shared across different projects and
could be used yeah right so so one is
the ASC we have it as separate you know
it's a separate project from the
compiler used to be in the compiler now
it's a separate repository
you know the type system is completely
independent there's other parsing I mean
that that's what I what I did here is I
created my own
[Music]
make sure that you maintain the right
order everything could just rewrite your
expression
I mean the other thing is that sometimes
the performant code is not the code that
you want to write so one example sort I
mean the performance code would be
compute ordering and then depart on the
ordering right but nobody wants to write
that because it's two lines instead of
one line so we could you know you can
write sort and then it gets translated
into ordering if you really want to okay
so I think it's premature
[Applause]